A little good old fashioned legwork.
Listen, we have different styles.
You're a man of action, which is fine.
Whatever we do,
we're playing God
we are gods.
who dies?
Think the hard choice.
You better walk away.
Come on.
You're the God
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
There's a bunch of new trailer footage
for Loki
Season 2 Episode 3 and Easter Eggs.
Especially the return of a Kang
Not the Kang you were expecting,
but the Kang that you needed.
There was a big teaser for them
finding another Kang during episode 2.
So we'll break it all down.
Some of this footage might be from episode
four, Episode five, too.
Marvel does that with mixed footage
from a bunch of different episodes
together for their series.
if you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
we're doing a giveaway for the Loki
Blu rays.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber
and post all your predictions for episode
three on the video.
Just based on the footage
Just starting at the beginning
of the trailer footage,
Loki and Mobius go back to what looks like
the 1890 Chicago World's Fair
to look for Victor Timely Kang,
who we just learned in episode
two, is from one of those three branch
timelines that survived.
How convenient that
there are a couple of Kangs out there.
for those that are wondering
what happened to the Council of Kangs,
they didn't reside in one of those
branches.
The council of Kangs is outside of time,
kind of like the TVA.
So that any changes to the multiverse
here, any changes to the branch timelines
don't affect it
the same way that
they don't affect the TVA, the same way
the reason why the TVA is breaKang down
is because the machinery that controls
the sacred time, that creates
the sacred timeline is breaKang down in
that's at the TVA,
basically those three surviving branch
timelines are operating like completely
alternate universe though, where
things are just a little bit different.
they don't say which number designation
this universe is in the trailer footage,
but in this universe,
Kang was born Daniel Richards
in the 30th century like he is
in every universe for the most part.
Up to a certain point,
all the Kangs are similar.
that at some point in their futures,
they all have some sort of divergence.
Like Lizard Kang here
eventually turns into a lizard.
this version of Nathaniel Richards
in his 30th century, eventually creates
the victor, timely persona
in travel to the 1800s and tries
to conquer the earth from the past.
Although he seems like he's a more
benevolent, a nicer version of Kang.
basically,
it amounts to the same thing, though.
He's going to the past to try and change
it using his advanced
knowledge from the future in the comics,
this is usually the same Kang
taKang on different personas
throughout his own lifetime,
trying to fight the different
Avengers characters
or doing different things in the MCU,
they're just saying that all the different
comic book versions of Kang
are from completely different universes
in the all only take on one persona.
So for instance, the Rama type
version of Kang in the Council of Kang's
is the only version
that he becomes in his universe.
He was never called
Kang the Conqueror in his universe.
He was only ever Rama to Notice
Loki and Mobius are wearing period
specific clothing
because it's a whole thing
we saw in episode two,
dressing up in seventies tuxedos
because they went to the zany movie
premiere in 1977.
But I do like that
we see Sylvie in the 1800 here
and it looks almost like she refuses
to wear period specific clothing
but she also has her own
heel remains tempered,
which is way more advanced than the ones
that Mobius and the other TVA agents use.
so it's not clear
if she goes to that alternate universe
with them to help them
or if she's just there on her own.
she might be just traveling
to those different branch timelines,
looKang for the dangerous variants of Kang
that Loki told her about,
like the Council of Kangs
that he warned her about.
we start to see a lot of familiar things,
like we see Victor time Lee's version
of Miss Minutes, who is old timey
because this is his whole vibe.
He's kind of like the Nikola Tesla
version of Kang in this scenario.
and because they explained.
The main version of Miss Minutes
was helping
Ren Slayer survive the timeline bombings.
She might have sent her to the universe
here in search of victory.
Timely Kang Because Miss Minutes is the
universe's most advanced supercomputer.
Most sinister supercomputer
to before the season one finale,
when she took off with Ren Slayer
to help her, she was processing
all of the multiverse data
coming through the TBS systems,
meaning she was monitoring
every single alternate universe
that he remains was allowing to exist.
They explained that the sacred timeline
is sort of like a rope of a bunch
of different timelines woven together.
That's why there were multiple universes.
When the sacred timeline
was the only timeline.
the only difference is the variations
like the other universes inside the sacred
timeline did not contain or did not give
rise to other dangerous Kang variants.
so he remains wasn't
preventing other universes from rising up
like there were other universes.
There was a multiverse
when there was only the sacred timeline.
He was just preventing other universes
from being created that gave rise
to other dangerous Kang variants.
Miss Min is used to have data
on everything, processing it in real time.
Like that's how powerful she was.
she be able to scan the other timelines
and find out which variants of Kang
would be helpful to Ren Slayer.
Like, go find this variant of Kang
in this universe.
He'll help you.
it also seems like Ren
Slayer was trying to get her memories back
even though it seemed like he who remains
loved her for some reason, at some point
he left the TVA, created the timekeepers,
started wiping her mind to
So it'll be interesting
to see what her reaction
is to like these other Kang variants
that we see during the season.
The whole idea, though, is that Obi teased
that they'd need a Kang
to unlock the control systems in the tbia
timeline control room.
Like they said, he
who remains, but obviously he remains died
at the end of season one.
since he's dead,
they need another Kang variant.
And there are three timelines
left to check
There are a lot of people that were asKang
about the particular temporal aura.
Like if it's a fingerprint,
does that mean that the temporal aura
of the different Kangs
in different universes are also different?
Would that mean that Victor timely Kang
that they bring back to the TVA to help
them was the person who really created
the TVA
we'll probably find out pretty fast, but
they might have just fudged that detail
when they were talKang about
temporal auras
because theoretically,
each of the different Kang's
different universes should have slightly
different temporal auras,
but they might just have some hand-waving
for that detail
and just say that all the different Kang
variants from different universes
basically read the same on detection
systems like, it's the same person.
They can't tell which one is bad
and which one is good.
but it does look like in the trailer
when they go back to the TVA,
Obi is super surprised.
man, it's you.
You're the guy that created the TVA.
that would mean that Obi remembers.
And a lot of people are wondering
about that, too.
Like he seems to remember a lot of things,
especially going back into the past,
like at least 400 years
that most other people don't remember.
so. Maybe Obi didn't have
his mind wiped the same number of times
that all the other people in the TVA did.
There also might be some twist
going on with his character too.
People are like,
Is he pretending to be somebody?
Like is he another Kang variant himself
Twist upon twist upon twist.
We'll see.
Then it looks like
they just have some comedy
with Loki and Mobius meeting Victor time
looKang in the past like Amy in the last
post-credits scene where they find him.
That was meant to be a scene
taken directly from the Loki season
two episodes.
Like they literally just copy
pasted it to the end of Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantumania During that, Loki
seems deathly afraid of meeting him
because they all assumed
that he who remains variants are dangerous
because that's what he told them
when they were in the future.
Like, if you think I'm bad, wait
till you meet my variants.
So he's assuming that he's going to be
just like he who remains.
Like we need to watch out my early theory
right now just based on the footage
because it seems like future timely Kang
goes back to the TVA to help them
is that they do fight briefly until Loki
realizes that he's a friendly Kang
who's happy to help them.
Look, that's the big twist. Like,
no, I'm not trying to kill you.
I'm not part of the Council of Kangs
in the same way, even though most
Kang variants seem
like they are part of the Council of Kang.
So that was what they said in the in the
WASP Quantumania Post-Credits scene.
the amortized version of Kang
said that he called
every single variant of Kang
to this council meeting.
So I think the idea is that
there's a lot of infighting
in the actual Council of Kang's like,
even though they're all on it in some way.
Some of them are more powerful than others
in not all of the different Kang's agree
with each other,
which is actually similar to the comic
book back story
behind the Council of Kangs.
I believe we saw a couple Kang variants
during this scene that we're going to see
during the season.
Like, I think that your time with Kang
is in the background here as well as Mr.
Griffin Kang, and I think
we'll also see him during season two.
Mr. Griffin Kang is the one that created
Kang Industries and took over the Avengers
tower in his timeline
there was a real quick blink
and you'll miss that Easter egg for that.
During Loki Season one, Episode
five on the Void planet
like it had been pruned It also seems like
Sylvie is going after Victor Timely Kang
also trying to kill him
the same way she killed he who remains
because she basically told Loki that like,
What are you going to do
if these other Kangs show up?
I'm going to kill him.
Just like I killed the other one
during the fight with the wren slayer,
with that old timey version of the TVA
taken with the pruning wand.
Because Victor time, this whole thing is
hyper advanced tech from the 30th century
that's very similar to he remains TVA
just made to look old timey.
I think this is meant to pay off
some of the Easter eggs
about the Council of Kangs back story
that he remains told them in season one.
Like for a little while
we shared information and technology
across universes to the betterment
of each of our own universes.
So many of the different Kangs
on the Council of Kangs all used similar
types of technology in their universes
with small subtle twists and Victor
Timeline's whole thing is being super
old timey like he old time travel machine
that he's trying to lecture them on here
like Nikola Tesla or Thomas Edison
lecturing people
about electricity in the 1800s.
there are couple of deep cut Marvel Easter
eggs here, too, in his presentation.
Like this is a marvel, like literally
the name Marvel, but also the name Victor.
Timely is an Easter egg
for the origin of Marvel Comics.
timely Comics
was the original name for Marvel Comics.
That was started by Martin Goodman,
who hired a young Stanley Lieber
Stan Lee, to work for him.
then they changed their name
to Atlas Comics.
Then they changed it to Marvel Comics
as you know it today.
there was also an Easter egg
for Timely Comics
during the Moon Knight series,
like Timely Atlas Productions
it also during Loki Episode
two for Martin Goodman in Timely Comics
They love to do that during all these
Marvel productions, Marvel movies,
Marvel basically referencing itself
during the original comics.
Victor Timely was a Kang variant
who traveled back to the year 1901
and created his own town called
Timely Wisconsin, maKang himself
the mayor basically
like creating his own little fight. Him.
He uses advanced technology
from the 30th century to build cars,
factories long before Henry Ford,
Thomas Edison could build their versions
of those technologies
and give the citizens advanced
knowledge beyond their period
they try to connect his town
with coronavirus, his city in the future.
The rules all the time from in the MCU,
that's basically the TVA.
That's kind of like
their version of principle is
eventually he bakes his death
and pretends to be his own son
and later winds up becoming the Prime Kang
like the most powerful version
of Kang by the events of a comic book
storyline called Avengers Kang Dynasty.
Doesn't that sound familiar?
Like, don't
we have an Avengers movie, Avengers 5
that's going to be called Kang Dynasty?
they're really just borrowing the title
of that comic book.
Like the actual plot of Avengers
five will be different from the plot
of the comic book Kang Dynasty.
during that storyline,
Kane tries to take over the earth
in order to try and save it in the future,
using his other cells
from different parts of his own timeline.
during the trailer
we see Loki using his magic again,
it looks like he gets knocked on his butt.
Rensselaer.
Also seems like she's jumping off
of a steamship onto this boat here.
And it also seems
like she's on the void planet here,
but she's still wearing the 1800s
clothing,
This is probably just Miss Minutes helping
her jump around different universes.
there's a couple other scenes
in different parts of the trailer
with Loki and Sylvie separately.
Either witnessing things being turned
into spaghetti or being turned
into spaghetti themselves
or things around them just in general
according to Obi, that basically means
that reality is breaKang down.
So this is like end of days kind of stuff.
Like their timeline
is completely breaKang down.
So some of that stuff might be scenes
from the actual finale or scenes
where Loki jumps forward to the actual
finale that they put in earlier episodes.
There are couple new scenes of Casey
in this alleyway, too.
Not sure which time period this is.
It looks a little bit
like it could be the 1800s,
but it could be a different time period.
there, also a couple Hunter B-15
scenes of her in a doctor's outfit
in what looks like a doctor's office.
based on all the footage.
Just post all your predictions
in the comments below.
Like I said, some of this footage might be
from like episode four, Episode five.
Marvel does that all the time.
Because we're in the middle of New York
Comic-Con.
Well, I'm posting this video.
A bunch of other trailers are dropping.
I just did a video
for the Invincible Season 2 trailer.
Click here to watch that and click here
for all my Loki episode videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!